zé la mobilisation autour du film de
virginie despentes dans un premier temps
le film avait obtenu son visa
d'exploitation assortie d'une sévère
mise en garde pour les spectateurs et
d'une interdiction aux moins de 16 ans
mais le conseil d'état saisi par
l'association d'extrême droite
promouvoir a jugé que le film devait
être classée x au nom de son caractère
pornographique et au nom des incitations
à la violence qu'il contenait pourtant
certains exploitants font de la
résistance et maintiennent le film à la
fiche
même s'il n'en autorisent l'accès qu'aux
plus de 18 heures dominique barrouche et
sellerie picot à la séance de 16 heures
dans cette salle parisienne le film de
virginie despentes hu faisait recette
son interdiction à tirer même du monde
fut le ratage qui a été fait
pouvoir la raison pourquoi est-ce que je
peux pas risquer dingo j'en ai eu
recours à google d'avoir des gens qui
soient
ban droit qui tient debout qui permettra
d'interdire aux gens veulent voir des
vies
vous verrez
oui tiens droit on se prend jamais
intéresse à cause du titre qui est
alléchant à contrer ce que j'en ai vu
dans les moments bonjour c'est pour quel
type d'attention contrôler ce que vous
avez une résidente été
tout le badine pas avec l'interdiction
aux moins de 18 ans quelqu'un peut venir
acheter un billet à l'avance et peut
aussi bien à leur donner à quelqu'un qui
a pas 18 ans donc pour éviter cela on
fait pareil des préventes
pourtant l'interdiction aux mineurs
émane de la direction du cinéma et non
du cncc même dans l'illégalité que huit
salles parisiennes diffuse le film perd
depuis vendredi soir le conseil d'état
lui a retiré son visa d'exploitation
ici c'est de la résistance il ya des
moments où il faut se mettre dans
l'illégalité
parce que on a des choses à défendre en
l'occurrence j'ai défendu toute ma vie
la liberté d'expression et ce n'est pas
maintenant que je vais arrêter car la
censure du conseil d'état contredit la
décision du ministre de la culture
d'autoriser le film aux plus de 16 ans
ce désaveu révèle même une véritable
lacunes du système français de
classification des films
il n'existe pas en france d'autres
moyens d'interdire un film aux mineurs
que de le déclarer x c'est à dire de lui
imposer de lourdes pénalités financières
qui condamne sa sortie en salles comme
nous avons séparé leur père légal de la
majorité à 18 ans et la réglementation
sur les visas nous sommes dans un trou
réglementaire
je crois qu'il faut y réfléchir
légiférer par décret exige de réunir
l'accord de tous les ministres concernés
une solution qui exige du temps